i'm tracy chadwell i'm the founding
partner of 1843 capital
1843 capital is an early stage venture
capital fund that invests in technology
companies
originally i went to law school and i
became a lawyer i had a dad it was a
lawyer and he said tracy the only sure
things are
death and taxes he was an estate
planning attorney and uh
and so he said you definitely should go
to law school and and you'll have work
for life
and so i did and i loved working
in law but it was there was always
something missing and so i decided to go
back and take some business courses
and started to work on the financial
side of things with
a merchant banking firm that i worked
for in chicago my life
has been really interesting and i feel
very lucky because i have a lot of
different
parts that have come together to create
one whole
so i've started from being an attorney
then working in financial services
and being an investment banker at
robertson stevens and then moving to
become a partner of a billion dollar
growth capital fund
one of the first women partners um i've
also taken some time off i've i've been
out in the field and been a mother for a
little bit so then when i came back
to starting my own firm i used all of
those pieces
to create what is now 1843 capital when
i was 52 years old i decided i think
it's
the right time for something like this
you know when i was at baker capital
i never saw any other women investors i
never
saw any women founders of companies and
all of a sudden we had this perfect
storm
of women being interested in building
businesses and
capital there to support them
accelerators
that were there to support them and uh
no capital
so i said you know what i think i'm
going to start first of all by investing
in women because they're not getting
enough
venture capital dollars so they were
getting 2.7 at the time and really the
number has not moved unfortunately
but um in finance we always look for
inefficient markets
and i thought wow what a perfect
inefficient market
so that's how i started and i developed
a terrific
track record and then i turned that into
starting my own fund
my message to women that are 20 and 30
years
old and and because i do a lot of
investing and longevity and technology
for the aging
is you're going to live to be 150 years
old
so enjoy yourself relax
i think what what has led to my success
is i follow the breadcrumbs and i'm
quiet and i listen i spend a lot of time
meditating
and if you follow the breadcrumbs you
won't get distracted
off on to a path that wasn't meant for
you because i really truly believe that
every person has a role
in this world and we all have a purpose
and if you if you're quiet
you can listen and find that purpose but
if you're distracted and you're running
around and you're
letting yourself focus on things that
are important
when people say to me what is it you
know how tracey how do i find my purpose
how do i know what i'm
meant to do first ask yourself the
question why are you pursuing what
you're pursuing are you pursuing
something because of fame
are you pursuing something because of
money are you pursuing something because
of
you know in either internal or external
expectations that are put on you
what you need to do is just be very
quiet and listen and then
things will opportunities will start to
present themselves and when it feels
right
that's the universe pushing you in the
right way if you're having a tremendous
amount of frustration you're either
really learning an important lesson or
you're being moved in a different
direction which is absolutely terrific
so take time look around you
be mindful and things will unfold